alors mais j'ai pris ça horrible c'est
vrai que votre vie vous avez triché en
fait
j'en appelle aux téléspectateurs étaient
deux acteurs dans son créneau attaques
personnelles ou alors ça fait trop est
ce que ça veut dire vraiment c'est
violent quand même
[Rires]
voilà la vérité la la j'ai ouvert les
profits lui en classe bien sûr vous
c'était genre le mec personnes devaient
baisser pas copier lui mettez un
classeur genre vous savez des mecs flou
qui mène les tractations avaient le mec
était calme
mais quand on use et mathieu à la semoy
l'abbaye du 2 avec la preuve
matthieu delormeau c'est vrai c'est le
gars en flash tu sors une bague de mouri
golf et veuille ou non si t'as pas envie
d'apprendre des frites salade
[Applaudissements]
ou nana qui va travailler
[Rires]
à une prof d'anglais ça fait mal
amérique ce d'ailleurs l'appeler astérix
se mêlent été comme as elles étaient
deux ou en train d'écrire au tableau des
cas l'enfant des cadets du grabuge
derrière c'est que ça
c'est pas
vous étiez comme ça je n'ai louis jamais
redoublé au dernier bulletin c'est vrai
j'ai gardé et marquer élèves intéressés
et intéressants
mais
[Applaudissements]
effectivement les gens comme vous j'ai
fui à l'époque non ah oui vous n'êtes
pas qu'un jour et moi pleurait
mais là il m'a l'école je la vois genre
un peu et quand même c'est la bonne
copine elle doit elle donner rigoler
quand même ouais mais elle travaille
bien elle veut pas déconner est ce à
dire que quand ça va trop loin madame
j'étais pas dans la sphère
[Applaudissements]
voilà
je pensais pas je suis
[Rires]
toutes les conneries des copains
un mec qu'elle kiffe et en plus en
classe mahdaoui le remets jour un mec
non un peu new wave genre non eh ouais
jour à led
ouais je crois que ça mousse du genre à
l'aide
à crier dans la cour
[Rires]
non mais c'est vrai c'était j'étais j'ai
laissé copié sur moi sans problème
j'étais bon élève et j'étais très
bavarde là ça c'est sûr alors à côté
nicolas pernikoff or lui en classe c'est
le seul gars en cm2 et pas eu copie
[Applaudissements]
11 m2 oui quant à
nico c'est
le gage chaussures ya des gars comme ça
ils font toujours vu ouais moi je me
rappelle par exemple commandant cousteau
ce qu'il fait on n'a jamais une tenté de
lui johnny c'est vrai on dirait qu'il a
été en bateau pendant des années
il avait un beau les frères ils vous je
vous ai je me corrige ou tatouage n'est
pas une tête ont si peu tête de l'eau en
fait non non s'il était déjà vieux ou
jeunes mais tanya quelles sont ces
médias 200
m à type l'onu
[Applaudissements]
nico qui place son biberon
vous n'étiez bonne élève ou non serait
très mauvais non c'est pas vrai je
copiais toujours sur les mauvaises
élèves donc
en fait toutefois dit qu'il avait été
mal un
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
drap son petit succès number gêne pas du
tout la nuit tombée d'abord j'étais tout
petit alors un petit peu épais mais j'ai
grandi d'un coup et de 6e et en 5e j'ai
eu tout à coup c'est de voir je suis
rentré en cinquième ah ouais je parle
comme ça donc je croise un tout le monde
m'entendait je lui apprenais est un
petit malin s'est surpassé en sixième on
l'a quittée ou là ils ont ils ont quitté
en
[Rires]
tube ou fou
d'abord
ouais là on connaît c'est la meuf que
tout le monde voulait percer sur la
c'est sûr mais ça lui va être un truc du
genre voilà le genre à toute la journée
elle elle est en classe et recevait des
papiers scooter
on envoyait les papés genre est ce que
tu veux bien sortir avec kim était
docteur louis non
moi je le rappelle je rajoutais nsp
nocerino
[Rires]
nsp tu vois j'ai beaucoup de respect ça
ne voulait pas problème mais bon elle
n'était pas chaude quoi la belle fille
c'est ça oui c'est exactement ça ou
alors veux-tu sortir avec nico donc ça
c'est les bons copains qui demande l
autre moitié
par exemple et donc j'ai très vite
appris la phrase je préfère qu'on reste
amis on va toujours bien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à
ces beaux arrêts non mais mais c'est sur
l'oreiller pg prg et moi mais moi c'est
en moi c'est pas des banques j'envoie
mon frère toute la journée je fais rien
en cas de jean bosco démons
mais moi tu es ce que tu vas sortir les
petits bouts non
mais j'en vois tous les jours je fais
que ça à faire voilà les mots qui
n'arrivait en loge tout à l'heure j'ai
dit amaury envoie un mot à delphine lui
que je veux partir mais
j'aurais un mot lui en classe lui je
suis sur lui en fait c'était le gars
mais qui se plaignaient de tous ouais
non mais je comprends pas pourquoi au
final 17 heures
[Applaudissements]
le gars
est ce que quelqu'un peut m'expliquer
pourquoi on abaisse de 15 à 10 est plein
d alarme incendie week-end on est sur
les rotules
ça y est c'est bon débat la semaine on
est mort je t'aime pas de mon temps j'ai
toujours des trucs de deux heures qui
servent à rien pas que ge pas que
charles a quelque chose le reste de la
journée non plus mais de 15h à 17h30 des
trucs qui servent à rien donc je
déclenche l avoir incendié
c'est une multi ça sert à rien et
chills abel en classe elle copé sur des
animaux sur des babouins
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
bouton vous à côté
[Applaudissements]
les crimes à peine sonnée pierre
et
[Rires]
vous accompagnent j'ai tout fait j'ai
accepté des mois des ennuis
[Rires]
[ __ ] j'ai fait des choses en
gt1 quand c'est ce qu'avait 5e où j'ai
redoublé de 20 heures doublée c'est vrai
d'ailleurs j'ai u 19 de moyenne générale
du rohrbach où j'ai eu la mention très
bien moi
j'ai fait plein de trucs comme moi par
maître du caca dans les chaussures
[Rires]
et facile
le problème c'est qu'en toile ans on est
mort elle va nous faire toute sa
scolarité on revient
à l'évêque non mais c'est vrai elle a
connu à elle a causé la grippe espagnole
est
arrivée au les gars c'est pas de ta vie
de la marche tu avais pas de passes
sanitaires devraient monter tu te
montrer patte blanche ça va tu vas voir
c'est 1789
c'est bien
bernard montiel toujours glandeurs
toujours debout
c'est sûr ils ne devaient rien faire
c'est à l'école mais il devait être au
courant de tous les votants m way
samba light au cinéma nature eric hier
soir mais ses leaders et celle de tout
le monde n'avait pas de nom mais lui
c'est lui en plus un oiseau de mauvaise
augure il allait voir les gars j'ai eu
et j'ai entendu un écho on s'habille pas
sûr que tu passais
[Rires]
le gars il a les mêmes bancs à l'épreuve
parce que lui il était proche et est
pote avec le proviseur
genre il a amené dans des soirées
proviseur et tout
genre il n'était pas avec le proviseur
toi donc il allait voir les preuves fais
gaffe parce que monsieur touchard
bouchées doubles à il pouvait deviner
sans et puis voilà était copain avec
montée ça ou pas oui c'est vrai mais je
n'aimais pas l'école et j'étais foutu le
bordel systématiquement ouais ouais ton
père n'avait pas changé à savoir ces
bavards emmerdeur les mots oui vous avez
déjà cerné mais pas en colère et a pris
je remonterai plus les bulletins il est
même plus jamais vu
je fais sciences économiques sociales
mais un bac b à l'époque et j'ai eu la
mention au bac a si bien non
il a eu la mention n'avait pas bien
entendu si bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
et enfin 3 décembre
j'ai triché j'ai triché ouais j'ai pas
la police
j'ai triché sur l'économie non les sauve
cause des les kolkhozes ça me faisait
chier c'est lé urss de l'esprit djoudi
est ce que j aime se dire les
téléspectateurs si oui on n'aimerait pas
passer une soirée claire
[Rires]
géraldine magnifique
je la vois c'est la mode déjà à côté de
qui tout le monde veut être tout à fait
c'est sûr tu vas être à côté des
tutoriels et sympathique avec l'essai
copier on sait qu'elle sait mais ça peut
être aussi à double tranchant parce que
j'irais me magnée on peut croire qu'elle
sait mais en fait elle s'est pas du tout
et ça c'est les pirates soit je me suis
fait piéger en contrôle en croyant le
gars était très bon parce qu'ils avaient
une bonne santé et en fait c'était une
balade
à dire qu'au bout de 15 minutes de
contrôle c se remarque est copié sur moi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est qu'un petit frère a perdu car
ce quatuor la côte est du frère est au
bout de dix minutes tu vois ça feu tu
fais mais est en fait tu lis frère tu es
en train de faire mieux
que moi je te le dis je te dire tu
passes à côté de tout contrôler c'est
très volontaires mais j'étais très
laborieuse ah ouais ouais et vous
bossiez beaucoup oui mais j'avais pas de
fulgurances bah ouais c'est vrai une
grosse pôle hard way est un moment
j'étais très complexée comme permis
coiffeuse et 1 m 82 n'ont jamais au
quatrième on a toujours une meuf comme
ça en classe quand vous êtes dans la
cour il ya tout le monde qui comme ça à
série a toujours une meuf des banques
avaient voté moi je rappelle c'était
carole benfica
arrivés dans la cour et a en plus tard
hall bencik elle voulait absolument
faire des casques h
[Rires]
garranah pour la moyenne est passée
comme un simple de la
moto de qualité toujours plus grande que
les profs c'est horrible je sais moi moi
moi mon fils il montre ses photos classe
parfois il ya toujours une meuf gillis
est la preuve une photo cc brimeux
bouchardeau
mes frères fait deux fois ta taille web
et columbus à pécho
est en fait j'avais l'accent du sud donc
c'était terrible mais c'est magnifique
action j'étais très complet en arrivant
à paris ont souhaité de ma gueule tout
le temps ah ouais bah écoutez voyez tout
ça c'est fini c'est d'ailleurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le seul mec quand ils arrivent à
l'école tous les profs u10 et un
guillaume genton si on peut demain venez
pas en pyjama
habillez-vous quand même voilà et
j'étais une énorme victimes à l'école
dans ce cas aussi minimisé par tout le
monde les élèves et les profs si si
c'est vrai j'avais montré complot
québécois en fait j'étais en surpoids ah
ben non on m'appelait carlos
[Rires]
ne pas se moquer sur ces bases tu as
montré siècle ils sont encore là parce
qu'ils doivent être encore sont quelque
part des environs et si quelques
noms mais l'ambition et en plus tu ne
ressens pas du tout
horrible ça c'est horrible bon c'est
vrai tu t'es ça va ça c'est grave
n'était pas blanc on en rigole mais
c'est vrai que llanelli la table
guillaume il en commet la tête ma vie
vingt deux joueurs tirent même à l'école
d'echery je vous dis rigoler entre vous
avec vous tous ensemble mais pas contre
quelqu'un regarde et nous voilà pris
sans ça je le vois pas où cela va non
mais c'est vrai mais
aussi carlos
série mon arrivée moi j'ai massacré mes
joueurs parce qu'on m'appelait moutons
frisé quand on tirait les cheveux
pendant tout le primaire mais c'était un
mouton qui a coûté la route 11
ce n'est pas fondé place tout et animaux
à l'école non mais c'est ok yamamoto
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]